guten morgen meine damen und herren ich
freue mich dass ich sie hier doch in
großer zahl wiedersehen darf nach einem
aufregenden
wahlkampf insbesondere auch an einem
aufregenden wahlabend am sonntag es ist
wichtig dass wir alle dabei auch gesund
geblieben sind es ist weiterhin auch
eine herausforderung für unser land und
insbesondere auch für eine zeit wo wir
viele andere aufgaben wahrnehmen müssen
umso mehr bin ich dankbar dass die
mehrzahl der wählerinnen und wählern der
sozialdemokratischen partei deutschlands
und eben olaf scholz als unserem
kanzlerkandidaten
vertrauen geschenkt haben was mich
persönlich überwältigt ich bin froh und
dankbar dass ich heute hier mit der
größten fraktion im deutschen bundestag
zusammen kommen darf es ist ein
besonderer moment wir haben eine
fraktion wo mehr als die hälfte der
gewählten abgeordneten neu in der
spd-fraktion sein wird ein
durchschnittsalter von etwa 45 jahren
ich finde eine gute mischung aus jung
aus älteren kolleginnen und kollegen
ganz
unterschiedlicher fachlichkeit und ich
freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit mit
206 kolleginnen und kollegen und ich bin
sehr dankbar jeder einzelnen jedem
einzelnen dass sie sich so angestrengt
hat ein fulminantes wahlergebnis für die
sozialdemokratische partei zu erreichen
wir haben viele direktmandate erreicht
wir haben in einzelnen bundesländern
alle direktkandidatinnen und kandidaten
die von den bürgerinnen und bürger mit
einem großen vertrauensvorschuss
ausgerüstet worden sind und auf der
anderen seite
sage ich wir stehen jetzt auch wieder
vor spannenden zeiten vor spannenden
wochen aber das tue ich auch mit der
notwendigen ruhe und auf der anderen
seite auch mit der notwendigen
überzeugung
vielen dank ihre fragen
bitten sagte fdp vize wolfgang kubicki
entscheidend ist dass es ohne grüne und
liberale keine regierung gibt befürchten
sie dass die beiden kleinparteien sie
bei den anstehenden verhandlungen da
über den tisch ziehen wollen
naja wer sich in rechenkunst jetzt
vielleicht bemüht der wird am ende
letztlich nicht den erwartungen der
menschen gerecht sondern es geht jetzt
darum dass wir für dieses land was am
anfang eines herausfordernden jahrzehnts
steht auf der einen seite ich hab eben
noch über die pandemie gesprochen aber
insbesondere
dass wir uns in eine klimagerechte
wirtschaft auch bewegen die aber auch
neue arbeitsplätze bereitet auch der
anderen seite war uns wichtig gewesen
auch in dem wahlkampf deutlich zu machen
dass wir einen mindestlohn brauchen dass
wir starke
tarifvertragsparteien aber insbesondere
auch starke gewerkschaften an unserer
seite haben müssen um den strukturwandel
auch gerecht zu werden es ist keine
rechenkunst sondern am ende ist es eben
auch etwas was hoffentlich liberalen und
grünen auch klar sein wird und mit einer
gewissen demut an diese aufgabe heran zu
gehen würde ich jedem selbst wenn er ein
erfahrener parlamentarischer ist auch
durchaus empfehlen
die sondierung hier dann steht sie sagen
heute morgen diese woche schon anfangen
und wann wird sie wird ihre langen
regierungsfraktionen denn nach ihrem
wunsch sozusagen im bundestag sitzen das
heißt wann sollten regierung geben
bislang naja erstmal ist es so dass der
neue deutsche bundestag sich in vier
wochen konstituieren wird und dann wird
meine fraktion als größte fraktion im
plenarsaal platz neben dürfen platz
nehmen können und das ist glaube ich für
jeden einzelnen egal ob er jetzt neu
gewählt wurde oder erneut in eine
weitere legislaturperiode startet ein
ganz besonderer moment ja wir haben
gestern im parteivorstand und im
präsidium mit olaf scholz und mit den
beiden parteivorsitzenden aber auch mit
malu dreyer und insbesondere auch den
wahlsieger rennen frau und frau schwesig
darüber beraten wie geht es jetzt in den
nächsten tagen weiter und das zeigt ja
auch noch einmal den besonderen moment
der an diesem donnerstag an diesem
sonntag gewesen war nicht nur
bundestagswahl sondern auch zwei
landtagswahlen wo die spd beide einen
großen wahlsieg aus meiner sicht haben
einfahren können und wir machen uns
jetzt konzentriert an die arbeit grüne
und fdp sind von uns eingeladen worden
mit uns wenn sie wollen auch in dieser
woche bereits sondierungsgespräche zu
führen
ich glaube beide kleinen parteien müssen
sich klar darüber werden dass das
schauspiel was sie vor vier jahren hier
manchmal auf balkonen
absolviert haben nicht den aufgaben
gerecht wird umso mehr hoffe ich dass
wir dann auch schnell zueinanderfinden
herr schäfer herr mützenich die fdp hat
im wahlkampf von roten linien gesprochen
die grünen haben gesagt sie wollen
unbedingt eine klima wenn der in der
nächsten bundesregierung was ist für die
spd was ist für sie unverhandelbar nun
es geht darum dass wir jetzt
konzentriert in die gespräche gehen die
frage von roten linien die einige
aufgezählt haben dass es deren
angelegenheit ich glaube dass die
menschen wollen dass sich ganz schnell
eine regierung und der größte wunsch der
menschen ist unter olaf scholz nicht nur
unseren kanzlerkandidaten sondern eben
dem überzeugenden mann an der spitze
dieses staates eben auch deutlich machen
kann wir haben immer gesagt wo unsere
prioritäten lägen
olaf scholz hat angekündigt im hinblick
auf den mindestlohn die frage des
wohnraums viele andere für uns wichtige
fragen die aber auch mit einem umbau im
hinblick auf die klimakrise deutlich
werden aber die eben die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer nicht
vergisst und das sind für uns natürlich
wichtige inhalte aber wir werden nicht
in der öffentlichkeit
koalitionsverhandlungen führen das haben
wir auch damals nicht als wir nach dem
die fdp und die grünen ihre gespräche
mit der union abgebrochen hat niemals
getan und ich will auch sagen für meine
person ist es mir lieber konzentriert in
den räumlichkeiten die uns zur verfügung
stehenden dann relativ schnell
entschuldigung zu ergebnissen auch zu
kommen er stellte nachfrage wenn sie
gestatten sie haben jetzt viele punkte
durchaus auch genannt im wahlkampf
spielte aber auch eine große rolle bei
der spd die frage von der erhöhung des
spitzensteuersatzes das haben sie jetzt
nicht mehr erwähnt aber ich
bin ja es geht gar nicht letztlich darum
was man jetzt
eben benennen sondern ich habe ihn
gerade gesagt dass ich finde wir sollten
diese koalitionsverhandlungen nicht in
der öffentlichkeit führen wir haben
nicht nur ein wahlprogramm sondern wir
haben überzeugende kandidatinnen und
kandidaten die den weg jetzt in den
deutschen bundestag gefunden haben auch
die werden dann wenn koalitionsgespräche
stattfinden daran beteiligt sein und
sollen sie gewiss mit ihrer großen
fachlichkeit wert eine starke die größte
es die größte fraktion im deutschen
bundestag auch ihren beitrag zu einem
belastbaren koalitionsvertrag leisten
also politische punkte sprechen zb
was als schwierigkeiten ich meine es ist
mit sicherheit
offensichtlich haben wir damit zu tun
dass der ein oder andere doch bei diesen
parteien sich mehr gedanken darüber
macht wo er in der regierung auf welchem
sessel der platz nehmen kann ich denke
wir sollten uns jetzt klar auf die
aufgaben konzentrieren und wir sind
bereit nicht nur schneller sondern auch
verlässliche gespräche zu führen wenn es
schwierigkeiten gibt werden sie auf der
strecke gelöst werden
wenn sie morgen gewählt werden als
fraktionschef im vorfeld hieß es sie
hätten eigentlich gar keine großen
lustenberger fraktionschef werden zu
wollen wieder und wenn die gewählt
werden gilt das für die
legislaturperiode unabhängig davon was
war sondierungen und regierungsbildung
herauskommt ja ich wundere mich immer
dass leute über meine lust nachdenken
ich trete für den fraktionsvorsitz an
der parteivorstand und das habe ich
gestern auch zur kenntnis genommen hat
der fraktion empfohlen
mich als kandidaten zu wählen das wären
wenn ich heute tun es ist bei uns
tradition dass wir zuerst mit der alten
und der neuen fraktion zusammen kommen
und dann werde ich meinen beitrag dazu
leisten dass olaf scholz kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird vielen
dank
weitere fragen sie sich nicht dann
bedanke ich mich unterhalten vielen dank
fürs interessen bleiben sie gesund
schönen tag danke schön